- Welcome, welcome.
Thank you so much for coming.
It's great to have all of you here today
on this beautiful day,
I mean really one of the
most beautiful days we've had
in New Haven, weather-wise,
for a long time,
and here you are indoors
thanks to your dedication
to the work that you're
gonna talk about today
and hear others describe.
I'm Steve Pitti, I'm
faculty in American Studies
and ER&M in History, and the
Director of the RITM Center,
and we've been looking
forward to this event
for a long time.
We were looking for an opportunity
to see you all in action,
to see people present about their work,
and just as importantly,
maybe more importantly,
give people the opportunity
to hear from one another,
because I think one of the
things that this place doesn't do
as well as it might is
give folks the opportunity
to engage with one another
about their work-in-progress,
about their research in progress.
Too often, all of us are sort
of dug in to our own projects,
stuck in our holes,
digging, digging, digging,
and we may not know who's digging what
just a few feet away from us.
So here we have that opportunity, right,
to learn from one another,
to think collaboratively,
to think across disciplines,
all more or less around topics
related to questions
surrounding race, indigeneity,
transnational migration,
and similar things.
So last year here in the RITM Center,
we had the opportunity, the
extraordinary opportunity
to support research
work by undergraduates,
graduate students, and professional
students around campus,
a total of 52 students from
all categories received
some form of support from us,
and we're really, really
fortunate and proud
that we were able to support
students from so many different
parts of the university, from
17 different departments,
programs, and divisions of the
university, both in this part
of campus, Central Campus, the
faculty of Arts & Sciences,
Yale College, the Yale Graduate
School, but also extending
out to the medical school,
the nursing school,
the art school, architecture, divinity,
forestry and environmental
studies, and so forth.
So this is what part of
our mandate is here in RITM
is to try to nurture and
enable that work in all parts
where we can help, and then
to bring that work together
in one place as best we can to make sure
that you all can hear from one another.
So we're excited about the
opportunity today to bring
that work together, to give
you the chance to present
and to hear from one another
about the work that you've done
and to make this space available,
to enable collaboration
and elaboration in the hour or so to come.
So what we have today is a
subset, a fraction of the work
that happened over the summer,
I think 12 presentations.
And we thank all of you
for being here today,
for answering the call as summer awardees
to come and share your
work with one another.
Thanks so much.
What we're gonna ask
everybody to do is to speak
for no more than three
minutes about their work.
We have put together a program,
and the PowerPoint presentations
are already in order,
so they will load automatically,
and that should make this
easier for everybody.
As you can see I'm holding a microphone.
We ask you to also hold the
microphone so we can catch this
on tape, and make sure
that this is recorded well.
We'll let you know when
you have a minute left,
and then when your time is up, so we hope
that you'll enjoy this,
settle in, have fun with this,
but also stick to time.
- Hi, my name is Ambre
Dromgoole, I'm in the Departments
of Religious Studies and
African American Studies.
Oh there we go, okay.
This summer while presenting
my research on 20th century
Gospel composer Roxie Ann
Moore at the Biannual Christian
Congregational Music
Conference in Oxford, England,
I had the opportunity to
converse and fellowship
with a group of scholars
researching Black sacred music
traditions spanning the Atlantic.
These discussions opened the
door for sustained global
conversation and collaboration
concerning the nature
of Black sound, consciousness,
and self-making.
From United States 20th century
Great Migration narratives
and the lasting impact of
Black Southern migrants
to Northern cities, on
Black expressive culture,
to the onset and effect
of the mid-20th century
Windrush movement of Caribbean
and West African populations,
creating a multi-faceted
Black-British community,
negotiating collective significance
against nuanced cultural
offerings and traditions,
the dialogue was incredibly dynamic.
This to say, in addition
to my own research
concerning the creation,
evolution, and innovation
of Black musical production
and sound as analyzed
and described through the
life of Roxie Ann Moore,
I was able to add this
Transatlantic component
to which she was also a
contributor and beneficiary
to my research which was a direct result
of my travels and RITM support.
While my initial work this
summer was supposed to follow
the trails of Roxie Ann Moore
and legendary 20th century
vocal group, the Golden Gate
Quartet, I found my work
taking different turns as a
result of robust conversation
held with my Black, British colleagues.
For example, letters I
found in Roxie's archive
prior to my travels
informed me of how the Gates
first arrived in Paris in
the mid-1950s to explore
new economic opportunities
after their light began to dim
in the United States, and music
labels started casting them
aside for seemingly brighter stars.
I knew that Black Americans
in the mid-20th century
viewed Paris as a place
of freedom and liberation
from the economic and racial
turmoil of the United States,
and that the ambassadorship of
jazz artists opened a window
for other Black musical artists and groups
like the Golden Gate Quartet
to find audiences in Europe.
But through this summer's
research, I learned that Windrush,
the mass migration of West
Indian and West African migrants
to Europe from the mid
to late 20th century
coincided with these
efforts, adding several other
dimensions to an ever-evolving
Black European soundscape.
During the Christian
Congregational Music Conference,
I learned that Trinbagonian
folk songs that migrants
brought with them, songs
combined with the sounds
of a burgeoning Gospel music industry,
scholars observed how
the commercialization
and commodification of Black
American sacred music practices
affected Caribbean and West
African artistic retentions
as they sought to adapt to new landscapes
while keeping home near.
Discussion surrounded the
Americanization of dialect
and pronunciation when
recording music came up
time and time again.
This experience has shifted
my research in a new
and dynamic directions,
and I'm grateful to RITM
for allowing me the opportunity to open
such a necessary dialogue, thank you.
(applause)
- Hi, I'm Michelle Johnson.
I am a second-year in History
and African American studies.
So my research looked at
the Civil Rights movement,
generally it looks at civil
rights movements in places
outside of the South.
So I start with the Great
Migration, starting around 1916
when Black folks were
moving from the South
up to Northern industrial
cities, and from there
I look at how those same
Black folks in cities
took their Southern roots,
took what was happening
in the South, and made the
Civil Rights movement their own.
So as Black Southerners moved
into Chicago specifically,
they set about rebuilding and
creating new institutions.
These included churches and
schools, as well as branches
of organizations like the NAACP
and Congress of Racial Equality.
Early on in the Civil Rights
era, many of these groups
were strategically made interracial,
which is how I found myself,
kind of unexpectedly,
looking at the papers of
Faith Rich, a white woman
who worked as an unpaid
staffer for the Chicago NAACP
beginning in 1945 and working all the way
until she passed away in the 1990s.
In her more than 50 years
living in a Black neighborhood
on the West Side of Chicago,
she involved herself
in nearly every education-related
battle for equality,
as well as political struggles
over urban renewal policies.
Though much of her work was
working on creating research
for reports, she was also not afraid
of door-to-door organizing,
doing a lot of block work,
or block-based organizing work.
Chicago's Civil Rights
movements were in some ways
very similar to movements in the South.
Much of the organizing
started with desegregating
restaurants and roller rinks,
but then went on to schools
and eventually housing,
and then eventually a lot
of Black Power-ish movements
working on Black business.
These individual movements
sort of broken down
issue by issue were also
happening all at once
throughout time and ended up
being continued over the period
starting around 1916 to 1970,
so while you can break them
down issue by issue, they also
were concurrent throughout.
In one of the most
dramatic moments in 1963,
200,000 public school students
stayed home from school
to protest inequality in public education.
Three years later, before the
schools came to a resolution,
Martin Luther King moved
into the city to fight
for open housing.
Local people on the ground
juggled these shifting priorities
as focus changed over time.
The majority of my sources up
to this point, doing research
for a couple years, were
not personal in nature.
So I looked a lot of reports created
by community organizations,
internal memos,
drafts of speeches, things like that,
but this was one of the first
archives that I came across
that had letters back and forth
to husband and wife, for example.
And I had to figure out
what to make of that.
It's a different type of source.
I had never had to come
across it, what do you do?
And I found that actually
it was really helpful
in piecing together what
the role of a white woman
in a Black activist position meant
and how she felt about
it and how she took it on
and how her neighbors felt about it
and how her family felt about it.
So it really shifted
my focus on my research
into not only Black folks
organizing about issues
that affected them, but
also the ways that coalition
was working in the city
of Chicago in this period,
thank you.
(applause)
- Hi, my name is Heidi,
I'm a senior History major
here at Yale.
This summer I was fortunate
to receive funding
from the RITM Center to
visit a series of archives
in the Midwest.
In particular, I was investigating
the relationship between,
the entangled relationship
between railroad expansion
and the White Earth and
Red Lake reservations
in Northwestern Minnesota in the late 19th
and early 20th centuries.
What I found increasingly
in my research by looking
at Indian Nation correspondence
and diaries and maps
and transcribed oral histories
was how much railroads really
affected both reservation
policies and Euro-American
settlers' access to these lands.
So in 1889, the Nelson Act
was established in Minnesota
that basically granted
settlers, Euro-American settlers
access and settlement
upon both the White Earth
and Red Lake reservations and
also allowed timber tycoons
to access these reservations.
So I started looking at
maps, for example from 1887
that showed a transcontinental
railroad passing
just south of the reservation
and all the lands in orange
represent lands that
were available for sale.
This reveals the degree of
pressure that railroads applied
on these reservations and
therefore allowed for settlement
on the reservations.
Likewise, only 15 years
later, we see the effect
of regional railroads and
the presence of railroads
on the reservations.
So this railroad, the Sioux
line, passed right through
the heart of White Earth
and just skirted Red Lake.
That allowed timber tycoons
and land speculators
to gain access to the
land, which in turn allowed
for the denuding of the
landscape and white settlers
to basically take over these reservations.
The effects of this railroad expansion
was just devastating for
the Native populations.
Here we see an Ojibwe woman practicing
her traditional maple
sugaring, and likewise,
other practices such as wild
ricing became very endangered,
because of the intensive logging practices
that were occurring because
of the railroad expansion.
And so we see basically
that how greatly railroads
are implicated in this process
of environmental degradation,
land dispossession, and
the cultural practices
that suffered thereafter.
And so I was just super
fortunate to engage with a series
of photographs such as the
one with Roland Reed here,
and all these different
maps, and Indian Nation
correspondence that just
shed light on this story
that's otherwise been somewhat neglected
in the historiography of the period.
Most people have focused on
just the policies themselves
instead of the vehicles
that allowed these policies
to be enacted, so thank you.
(applause)
- Hi, my name is Jacqueline
Ly, I'm a third-year History
Ph.D student studying
Latin American history.
And this summer I went
to London for my research
thanks to money from RITM.
So my research is on the Bay of Honduras
and the Mosquito shore
in the 18th century.
So the Bay of Honduras occupied the region
that is today Belize, you'll
see it in yellow on the map
labeled British Honduras.
And the Mosquito Shore
occupied the Caribbean coast
of modern-day Southern
Honduras and Nicaragua,
so it comes down, the pink and green here
on the right side of the screen.
So the significance of the
time and place come into play
in the context of early
modern Atlantic empires.
Here specifically we're
dealing with Britain and Spain,
and Spain by right of
discovery and the authority
of the Papal Bull of 1493
claimed absolute sovereignty
over the entire expanse of
the Americas west of the line
drawn in the Treaty of Tordesillas.
So of course, this is
how it worked in theory,
but in reality, Spain
didn't have the manpower
and the Spanish authorities on the ground
didn't have the inclination
to completely explore
and take a hold of the territory
in all of Spanish America.
And especially on this
Caribbean coast of New Spain,
the terrain was jungle-filled
and the coastline
was treacherous, and so
Europeans really made few entries
into this region.
The British eventually
came to get a foothold here
in the Bay in particular,
in the yellow area.
And as the historiographic myth goes,
in the Golden Age of Buccaneering
as it comes to an end,
the buccaneers who would've
been among the best sailors
of this region would have
been able to navigate
the treacherous Keys and
reefs coming into the Bay,
so you can see the map of the water
as it moves around these islands.
It would've been really
hard to actually access
the landmass of this
coast of Central America.
So as Jamaica changes
hands from Spain to Britain
in the late 17th century, and
sugar planters are beginning
to establish their
lucrative businesses here,
the European powers agree
that buccaneering needed
to come to an end in this new
age of order in the Caribbean.
So as a result, the buccaneers
who had been operating
in the Caribbean sought
new sources of income,
and they turned to enterprises
they had already been
starting, which were
cutting logwood and mahogany
from this region.
So as these trades expand,
Spain and Britain begin to vie
for sovereignty over the region,
and the traditional story
that's told of this is about
an Anglo-Spanish conflict.
So my question in researching
this has been challenging
the historiography to look at other sides
that are not simply about
European sovereignty,
and specifically about
the Mosquito Indians
who actually held territorial, political,
and political control of this region.
And a geographer Karl Offen
writes that this region
was only called Mosquitia
or the Mosquito Shore
because of the Mosquito's
spatial practices.
Otherwise it would have
only been some other place
in Central America.
So my research looks at
how the Mosquito Indians
were not only crucial in
facilitating European forays
into the region, but also
I'd like to take seriously
the words themselves, so for
example, why has sovereignty
not been used in the
historiography of this region?
And how can we apply
that, taking into account
contemporary challenges that
the Mosquito people still face
with the Nicaraguan government
and questioning the ethics
and how far we can actually
push the history and questions
in this region, so that's my work.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Hello, my name is Ever Osorio.
I'm a third-year in American Studies
and Women, Gender, and Sexuality Studies,
and this summer I had opportunity
to do archival research
which is something that
I've never done before,
so I wanna thank Steve
for gently pushing me
in the last two years
to go beyond my methods
and improve them.
So I guess that one of the
gains was to not be scared
anymore of the archive, and I
think that's a big, big step.
So I had opportunity
to gather, make friends
with the archival people,
and get to know materials,
how to do research, how
is the archive organized,
so I kind of learned that.
And my question was, well,
what is the global circulation
of contemporary art on the War on Drugs?
And why level of circulation,
because I wanted to see
how there were different interpretations
of the Mexican War on
Drugs, which is my main area
of research, in aesthetics,
as how we are feeling
this violence from a global perspective.
So I went to four archives.
The first one was MUAC,
which is Museo Universitario
Arte Contemporáneo,
which is University Museum of UNAM,
which is the main public
national university in Mexico.
And there what I found was fascinating
because I found embroiderers
which were women
that embroidered the name of
victims of the war on drugs,
of casualties, so it was
very interesting to see
how I had forgotten about that,
like I had forgotten
about all those visual
artistic manifestations
that had been taking place
in the last 10 years,
so that was, in a way this research
was also self-autographic,
because I found a lot of stuff
that I forgotten, like what
was forgotten was for sure one
of the most important elements
of this historical record.
Then I went to Paris
to the Centre Pompidou.
I found nothing, but
that absence is important
because it really speaks
of the circulation of art
and the geographical distribution
of certain topics or concerns.
Then I went to Kassel in
Germany, where documenta,
one of the most important
contemporary art fairs takes place
every five years, and there
what I found were more ...
Since I'm not looking for history
or a particular historiography,
I am mostly looking
for metaphors or, I don't like
the word "sign," but symbols
that let me think beyond
what I'm already thinking,
so I found a lot of metaphors there.
And finally I was in
Venice, where the Biennale,
the Venice Biennale,
which is the oldest contemporary
art fair, takes place.
And this is the work Teresa Margolles,
she is one of the most relevant
contemporary Mexican artists
and the name of this art
piece is "The Surge,"
and it's relevant because it
shows posters of the government
looking or searching for
women that are missing,
and what is so sadly and painful
is that these are from 2009, 2011,
so when we see the massive
demonstrations of women
in our hemisphere, we can see
how old that phenomenon is,
so that's what I found.
(applause)
- Hello, my name is Héctor Peralta,
and I'm a third-year Ph.D.
student in American Studies.
Today, our public schools in
the U.S. are as segregated
as they were when the Supreme Court ruled
in Brown Vs. Board of Education.
What's more, states like
New York and California
are among the most
segregated of those states.
But how did we get here?
Well, by the 1980s,
Constitutionally-mandated integration
of schools had been largely
undermined through legislation
like California's Prop 21,
which prohibited mandatory busing.
Today, schools continue to
contend with the effects
of white flight, redistricting,
and the rise in private
and charter school enrollment,
yet state-funded school
programs working to improve
graduation rates and increase
access to higher eduction
largely ignore the realities of inequity
produced through school segregation.
One such program is AVID, which stands
for Advancement via
Individual Determination.
In 1980, a high school English teacher
named Mary Catherine Swanson
founded the AVID program
at a public high school
in San Diego County.
As schools restructured
to accommodate for changes
in student demographics
and budget capacity
caused by factors like
refugee resettlement
and the privatization of
education, AVID was advertised
as a remedy, an educational innovation
to close the achievement gap.
Today, AVID is offered in 47 states
and 16 countries worldwide.
In popular coverage, Swanson
is celebrated as a visionary
educator with a plan and
the gall to disseminate it.
Yet these very accounts
celebrate her individual grit
and tenacity without emphasizing
the collective of mentors,
educators, and
administrators that make AVID
as successful as it is.
Even the name, Advancement
via Individual Determination
pushes forward a neo-liberal
vision of public education.
It is up to the individual
student determination
if they go to college.
So my research asks, how is
the resegregation of schools
and the unequal distribution of resources
rendered invisible behind
programs like AVID?
Furthermore, how is the
AVID pedagogy implemented
in other education programs
designed for indigenous
and migrant communities
within the San Diego region?
With the support of RITM,
I conducted archival
and ethnographic research
this summer to examine
how different educational
institutions in San Diego
address the achievement gap in schools.
Primarily I worked at the
Viejas Tribal Education Center,
or VTEC, located on the
Viejas-Kumeyaay Reservation
in East County, San Diego.
VTEC provides after-school
tutoring, college readiness
and life management skills
workshops for students
who are children of
enrolled tribal members.
In an oral history I
conducted with Teresa,
the high school student
coordinator at VTEC,
she stated the greatest need
within the public school
district is tutoring
services for all students,
not just those in AVID
or those at part of VTEC.
Looking forward, I will
analyze how a collaborative
mentorship functions
differently across AVID, VTEC,
and YALLA, which is a non-profit
that uses a combination
of after-school tutoring and team soccer
to prepare migrant
students to enter college.
As San Diego County continues to lead
in refugee resettlement, I
hope my research will support
and promote pedagogies of and
for liberation, thank you.
(applause)
- Hi everyone, my name is Teanu Reid.
I am a joint-Ph.D. student in History
and African American Studies.
If I asked everyone to take
out some money right now,
you might pull out a dollar bill, a coin,
or even a debit or credit card.
It wouldn't be difficult
for many of us in the room
right now, but there was a
time in the early modern period
where money was not
standard, and if I asked
the same question in the
17th or 18th century,
you might pull out a Spanish
piece of eight, a French livre,
English or Dutch bills of
exchange, and you could all be
in the same British colony.
For my research, I am connecting
this early modern history
of the complicated monetary supply
with the rented out
labor and Sunday markets
of Africans and their descendants,
particularly I am exploring
the economic activities
of freed and enslaved
people of color in Barbados,
Jamaica, and South
Carolina from 1650 to 1770.
I am tracing their sources of income,
the economies they participated in,
and how their lives too were affected
by the early modern monetary supply,
wondering how they paid
for their manumission,
wondering how they paid for
rent, for clothes, for food.
Through my analysis of the
money of freed and enslaved
people of color, I hope to
provide an early modern basis
for thinking about economic inequality
not only in terms of the
difference for how much money
people have, but also in the difference
in the types of money that
people have access to.
And finally I hope to create
a interdisciplinary dialogue
between the fields of history,
finance, and Black studies.
To complete my project,
this summer with the support
of RITM, I went to the
British National Archives
where I explored several
colonial office records,
in particular I'll name two:
the Colonial Office Records
2815, which contain several
letters about the illicit trade
between Barbados and the French,
and then Colonial Office Record 137/2
that contains similar
documents with relation
to Jamaica's illicit
trade with the Spanish.
Collectively, what these
documents show is that,
do-do-do-do-do-do-do,
whether or not, sorry, one second,
primarily I would argue from these sources
that the support for piracy
that went on sometimes
under the table by these
colonial governors shows
that there was a desperation
for money in the colonies,
and that there was a definite
means to procure money
through illicit trade,
and with further research,
I am going to show that the
currency from this trade
ended up in the hands of
freed and enslaved people
and was important to their survival
in these colonial spaces.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Hi, my name is Gabi Rivera,
I'm Mapuche, I'm a senior,
an ERM major, I'm an
undergrad, and I'm using images
of street art in Chile,
around Santiago and Temuco
that I collected this past summer
to look at indigenous
Mapuche urban identities
and resistance today against
state-sanctioned violences
directed against indigenous
communities in Chile.
And one question that
I ask is to what extent
are these artworks
examples of manifestations
of Mapuche resistance, because
urban spaces are oftentimes
not seen as spaces inhabited
by indigenous peoples,
and therefore this becomes
indigenous space reclamation.
They can be self-erected
memorials to victims
of police brutality, like Matías Catrileo,
who was murdered by a police officer.
They can address hydro-electric
company encroachment
on Mapuche lands, the
desecration of burial sites,
or current Mapuche political prisoners,
like Francisca Linconao who was arrested
under Chile's anti-terrorism
law, because the state
oftentimes perceives Mapuche
people as terrorists.
Linconao is currently still
in prison for her resistance.
I also asked to what extent
do some of these murals
in the heart of Santiago point to an issue
of multiculturalism in the Chilean state?
Or the concept of promoting
diversity politics in a country
oftentimes while still maintaining
discriminatory policies
toward specific racial and ethnic groups.
In Chile, one of the tenets that allows
the multicultural state
to function is the concept
of "mestizaje," which is
typically defined as the mixing
of white-Spanish, or colonizer
blood, with indigenous blood,
to produce a quote-unquote
new race, or the Mestizo.
And I'm going to refer
to it as an ideology
in an engagement with Mapuche
poet Daniela Catrileo's work.
She refers to mestizaje
as a colonizer ideology
which promotes the assimilation
of indigenous peoples
into white society.
And this further supports
the settler state
by promoting a diminishing
of indigenous communities
through a pattern of
self-identification with whiteness,
and it creates a racial hierarchy
with the quote-unquote
actually indigenous peoples
at the bottom and then Mestizos
and whiteness on the top.
Many Mestizos claim Native
heritage or ancestry,
which relegates our
indigeneity to the past
as belonging to history,
rather than as an active part
of ourselves today and
promotes stereotypes
such as vanishing Native people
and that indigenous
peoples are disappearing.
Mestizos in Chilean society
are oftentimes the one
enacting violence against Mapuche people,
and enacting the violence
on indigenous communities
that they perceive themselves
to no longer be a part of.
The street art in Chile
gets at complex layerings
of identities and of the presence
of a white settler state,
and ultimately I'm gonna draw parallels
between Chilean street art
and settler-state violences
to transnational settler-state
violences protested
by indigenous produced murals
in neighborhoods of color
that I've also collected in
Baltimore and Washington, D.C.,
like murals containing
images of Freddie Gray
or Trayvon Martin, and I wanna
draw attention to a variety
of human rights violations and injustices
that settler-states legally
and systemically perpetuate
that we continue to confront today.
(speaks in foreign language)
Thank you.
(applause)
- Hi, I'm Sylvia Ryerson.
I'm a second-year American Studies Ph.D.,
and the RITM summer research
fellowship supported 10 weeks
of field research for
me in Eastern Kentucky
on mass incarceration
in Central Appalachia.
Since the 1990s, Central
Appalachia has become
one of the most concentrated
areas of rural prison growth
nationwide, and many of
these new prisons are built
on formerly strip mined,
mountaintop removal mined land.
And so my initial research
goal was to document transfers
of land ownership from coal
companies to prison sites.
However, within my weeks of
first arriving in Kentucky
this summer, one of my research
sites, there was major news
that broke regarding
the pending construction
of a new federal prison in
Letcher County, Kentucky,
and this is the prison proposal
that was first proposed
to the county in 2008, and on June 20th,
the Federal Bureau of
Prisons withdrew its record
of decision to build USP
Letcher, which was projected
to become a $510 million
new high-security prison.
This effectively defeated
what was slated to become
the most expensive federal
prison ever built in US history.
So due to this historic turn of events,
my research took a different
direction, and I focused
on the 15 years of local
and national organizing
that made the defeat of
this prison possible,
and you can see this is the proposed site,
and this is a strip
mine, and I interviewed
many different people including
some local landowners,
and so here is one of my interviews.
- [Mitch] And they were gonna try to split
right across everything,
and they could bullied him!
They coulda said, look, that's our coal.
- [Sylvia] Yeah.
- [Mitch] The best way to get to it
is right across your land.
This has already been signed over to us,
but I think from what I
done, they were forced to go
another way, and again
they went up the road
about half a mile and
(murmurs) winding road
to the top of that, and all
of that coal was brought off
another way, but they wanted
to come off Brent Ball side,
and had it not been for them
telling you got the right,
you know, they done, they could ...
And it woulda busted my,
right away my grandfather's
big cow pastures where he
kept his cattle and stuff,
he would've, you know, just
been off his mess, there it was,
he wouldn't have been
able to use it, you know,
it would've took up half of his land.
And it would've been terrible
to have seen it split down
there, and that's what I
thought was gonna happen again.
Really, really was.
- That's what I thought
was gonna happen again.
That's Mitch Whitaker who owned 15 acres
of this 700-acre site, located
his opposition to the prison
within the genealogy of
organizing that his grandfather
and his father were a part of,
was opposing radical
strip mining in the 1970s,
so that's what you
heard him talking about.
And his refusal to sell
these 15 acres delayed
the whole project two
years and was pivotal
in ultimately defeating this
proposal, and he ended up
joining a historic lawsuit
alongside 21 incarcerated people
across the country that
sued the federal government
against the prison being
constructed on the grounds
that it would cause unnecessary harm.
So this research is essential
to a journal article
I'm currently co-authoring,
observing what this ROD,
record of decision withdraw reveals
about the current contradictions
of the US carceral state,
and how a multi-sided coalition
of organizers, advocates,
and landowners strategically
exploited these contradictions
and created this space for
radical and groundbreaking
opposition to the carceral
state to emerge in a place
many might not have expected
or thought possible.
(applause)
- Hi everyone, my name is Aanchal Saraf,
and I'm a third-year in
American Studies and WGSS.
This summer, I did a
combination of ethnographic
and archival work in order
to consider the history
of indigenous anti-nuclear
organizing in the Pacific
through an organization
known as a nuclear-free,
and independent Pacific movement.
So the poster that is on,
this poster right here,
as well as the two photographs above
are both historical photos
from NFIP mobilization.
I also considered the material traces left
on Pacific Islanders subject
to nuclear detonations
whose landscapes and displacement
point to the still present
nature of 20th century
wars in the Pacific.
The aerial photo of Majuro
Atoll in the Marshall Islands
depicts the ethnographic
space in which I began to ask
the latter question more intently.
And I took that photo
from the plane window.
For my research, I visited
the National Archives
of Australia and Canberra,
and the National Archives
of Aotearoa, or New
Zealand, in Wellington,
as well as the archives at
UH-Manoa in Honolulu, Hawaii.
I also did preliminary
field work in Majuro
in the Marshall Islands.
I have a few primary takeaways
from this experience.
First, the politics of the
archive are deeply enmeshed
with empire's entanglements
within climate change,
as many documents formerly
available in the Marshalls
were lost due to disaster events,
or moved to imperial archives
due to sea level rise.
Second, the Black Pacific
is a generative terrain
of contestation within 20th
century social movements
in Oceania, especially
in the ways that troubles
divides between Blackness and indigeneity
in order to provide a
fulcrum for solidarity,
and that's me, I think,
riffing on Manu Karuka's
ideas of fulcrums for solidarity.
Third, war is immediate in the Marshalls.
It happened, it is happening,
it could happen at any given moment.
These coexisting temporalities remind me
that as I imagine liberatory
Pacific Islander futures,
I must also account for the
colonial and settler futures
already set in the motion
by the artifacts of war,
such as unexploded ordinances,
human bones in various stages
of repatriation or loss,
and American military ships
resting in the fishing
lagoon, parts breaking off
and breaching sand where children play.
Finally, Pacific Islander
women and queer people
are and have been at the helm
of these trans-indigenous movements.
The sovereignty of their
bodies is a critical foundation
to further liberation.
While these are just a
handful of the revelations
I had doing research this summer,
they speak to a much larger examination
of nuclear colonialism
and indigenous resistance,
as well as the transformations
of race that emerge
from the migration catalyzed
by these unfolding processes.
I thank RITM for funding this work.
It has proven to be an
extraordinarily enriching summer.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Hi everyone, my name's Monique.
I'm a Ph.D candidate in
the Department of History.
So, two photo albums sit side by side
in the archives at UC Berkeley.
One of them, filled
with mugshots replicated
from a long lost set
of original photographs
in the early 20th century.
Under each mugshot, detailed descriptions
of what the men wore, their hairstyles,
and other information
that according to the eyes
of a Mexican anthropologist
and his research assistant
told us just what "type"
of Mexican men these were.
Another, filled with
photographs just like this one,
of men standing in a field with
either cows, cars, or horses
in the background and little
to no information about them
beyond that they're from the late 1920s
and perhaps a name and a hometown.
In another archive on the
other side of the Bay Area
sit a different set of records.
Mexicans entering the
US through Angel Island
whose names, birthdays,
kinship networks, jobs
enter the historical record
through immigration workers
and are found actually
in national archives
of Chinese exclusion.
All of these archives are
part of how Mexican migrants,
from the middle class escaping
the Mexican Revolution,
to migrant peasant workers laboring during
the Great Depression in
agricultural fields in the US,
enter the historical record,
shepherded in by how a set
of experts or so-called
experts understood them.
Anthropologists, economists,
INS workers, the border patrol,
photographers, and bureaucrats
of all sorts on both sides
of the US-Mexico border,
from 1910 to mid-century
were heavily concerned with
Mexicans entering the US.
But also of what type of
Mexicans were entering,
of how to racially categorize
them, of how to understand
and read what they are,
according to so-called experts,
and what they saw in their
faces, clothing, and hairstyles.
This is a story made up
of different threads,
of how different experts were
establishing and solidifying
the racial category of Mexican in the US
at the same time that Mexican
experts were solidifying
a national, almost mythical,
Mestizo-Mexican citizen
after the Mexican Revolution.
Both were taking place in
relation to massive migrations
of Mexicans within Mexico and in the US,
and they specifically were
concerned with how one saw them.
What did their clothes tell these experts
about economic station?
What did their hairstyles
tell them about their racial
locations, about their
gender presentation,
and about who they were?
In short, what did one see
when looking at a Mexican?
These are questions that enter the archive
along with the photographs
and textual records
that these experts have
used to try to figure out
who these Mexicans were, how
they fit into the racial matrix
of both the US and Mexico,
and how citizenship
was being fashioned on
each side of the border,
but also between them,
dependent on what one saw
when looking at a Mexican.
This is the project that I have
taken on for my dissertation
and that has slowly come
together in no small part
thanks to the generous
funding and support of RITM
over the last summer, allowing
me to visit these archives,
sit with the stories of these migrants,
and to begin to figure
out what it is that I see.
Thank you.
(applause)
- All right, I'm Adam
Waters, I'm a second-year
History Ph.D. student, and first of all,
it's just really wonderful
to be able to share my work
alongside all of you, so thanks for that.
So on March 24th, 1982, a rally was held
at South Side Presbyterian
Church in Tucson, Arizona
to declare publicly that the
church would provide shelter
to migrants fleeing systemic
violence in Central America.
Over the next several
years, hundreds of churches,
synagogues, mosques, and other
religious communities joined
the Sanctuary Movement in
supporting migrants and protesting
the Reagan administration's
policy towards Central America.
Likewise, a constellation of
committees and organizations
were birthed to shepherd the movement
at the local, regional,
and national levels.
And as is common with political movements,
especially those on the left,
numerous and often serious
disagreements emerged
over, among other things,
the political orientation
of Sanctuary, and the role
of Central American migrants
themselves in the movement.
So the Sanctuary Movement was
the subject of intense media
coverage and a good deal of
scholarly research in its time,
but given where we find
ourselves today with renewed
conversations about migration
from Central America,
about migrant detention
and deportation regimes,
and with the emergence of
a new Sanctuary Movement,
I think it's an opportune
moment to revisit
the 1980s Sanctuary Movement.
So this summer I spent a month in Tucson
conducting initial research
on the Sanctuary Movement
and its historical legacies.
My research was primarily
archival, exploring several
Sanctuary-related collections
at the University of Arizona,
but I also had the
opportunity to get involved
with local organizations currently working
in humanitarian assistance
and advocacy for migrants,
many of which were created and staffed,
sustained by former Sanctuary workers.
My time in the archives
and my conversations
with migrant justice activists
have sparked a number
of questions that I hope
to consider moving forward,
and so I'll outline just a
few conclusions from my summer
and avenues for further research.
So first, most works on
Sanctuary have either focused
on a local level and its
manifestations in a particular city
in Tucson, in Los
Angeles, in San Francisco,
or on the actions of
its national leadership.
But the documents that I found made clear
that the Sanctuary Movement
needs to be approached
as a multi-scaler phenomemon.
I hope to document the
relationships and the dynamics
between actors at various
scales in order to present
a more comprehensive
sense of how the movement
operated as a whole.
My research this summer also made clear
that the Sanctuary Movement
was a transnational
and international movement.
So Tucson-based activists
were working closely
with church leaders in
Central America and in Mexico
to develop what they called
an underground railroad
that brought migrants through
Mexico across the US-Mexico
border and into sanctuary
in the United States.
So far no one has really
been able to document
how this trail actually
functioned, particularly how
it functioned outside of the
borders of the United States,
and so I imagine that my work
in the future will involve
conducting field work in
northern Guatemala and in Mexico.
And finally I think there's a
lot more to be done to think
about how the Sanctuary Movement
fits into larger histories
of immigration policy,
migrant justice activism,
left politics, and progressive religion
in the late 20th century
in the United States
and in Latin America.
I'm particularly interested
in situating sanctuary
as part of an emerging
migrant justice praxis,
one that stretches from the
1970s through to the present.
Thanks.
(applause)
(low chimes)